Brazil has now surpassed China's
official death toll from the coronavirus
but the country's president continues to
downplay the threat from the virus that
is raising concerns that outbreaks in
Latin America could lead to another wave
of infections here in the United States
Manuel Bojorquez has that part of the
story but we do want to warn you some of
the images in this report are graphic
there is no denying the corona virus is
ravaging Brazil topping 90,000 confirmed
cases and with more than 6,000 deaths
President jarba senado who sneered at
the threat from the start said this
about the rising toll I'm sorry what do
you want me to do instead local
officials were left to implement
lockdowns Brazil's crowded poor
neighborhoods or favelas are fertile
breeding grounds here disinfecting is
often do-it-yourself meanwhile Bo Sanada
last week joined anti lockdown
protesters no masks or social distancing
here despite the grim situation
throughout the region Ecuador is
suffering one of the worst outbreaks in
its largest city Guayaquil some bodies
went uncollected for days the
president's cabinet secretary who on
Sebastiaan ruled on told us this week
that both new cases and deaths have
decreased dramatically in recent weeks
but did confirm the country's official
death toll in the hundreds is a vast
undercount we assume there could be more
than 6,700 deaths due to corona virus
but we can't prove it because the
testing wasn't done he told me social
distancing here worked but it was a
tough sell given half the nation's
workers are part of the informal economy
largely street vendors we know that in
Ecuador it is fundamental to get back to
work he said adding some restrictions
would slowly be lifted in certain places
but with cases rising in neighboring
countries like Peru Latin America's
fight against the virus is far from over
for CBS this morning Saturday and
Orcas Miami